[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir bonsoir tv
merci merci et bonsoir merci luis le
membre du congrès américain avant qu'il
ne meure a écrit que la démocratie n'est
pas un état
conceptuel mais qu'il s'agit d'une
action à faire c'est à dire que la
démocratie américaine n'est pas garanti
elle l'est aussi forte qu'à la mesure de
notre volonté de nous battre pour elle
[Applaudissements]
dans la mesure où nous voulons être les
défenseurs de notre démocratie
protéger notre démocratie cela requiert
des sacrifices
il faut se battre pour elle mais cela
recèle d'une joie car le progrès est
possible par l car nous le peuple avons
le pouvoir
nous pouvons bâtir un meilleur avenir
oui lorsque notre démocratie même était
en jeu aux suffrages dans cette élection
puisque l'âme même de l'amérique était
en jeu et que le monde entier nous
regarde et vous vous avez permis qu'un
nouveau jour puisse poindre à l'horizon
[Applaudissements]
au personnel les membres de notre
campagne aux bénévoles
vous êtes une équipe extraordinaire
alors nous vous remercions remercie
d'avoir pu réunir plus de gens que
jamais auparavant qu'ils ont pu
participer à notre processus
démocratique et merci d'avoir pu rendre
possible cette victoire aux différents
officiels qui ont travaillé aux
élections dans les différents centres
électoraux de dépouillement qui
s'assuraient que chaque vote compte
notre nation vous dois beaucoup de
gratitude y aura fait tracter vous avez
de fait protéger l'intégrité même de
notre démocratie et au peuple américain
je veux dire vous composer notre monde
notre le peuple magnifique merci d'avoir
participé et grâce à vous vos voix
seront entendues
je sais que les derniers temps ont été
difficiles surtout les derniers mois il
a eu beaucoup de douleur de tristesse de
défi de préoccupation et de difficultés
mais nous avons été témoin également de
votre courage notre résilience et de
votre générosité votre esprit est empli
de générosité durant quatre ans vous
avez marchés emprunter le sentier de
l'organisation vous avez vous êtes
battus pour l'égalité et la justice pour
défendre nos vies et défendre notre
planète
et alors vous avez voté
à new delhi vous avez lancé un message
clair vous avez choisi l'espoir et
l'unité la décence la science
et oui vous avez choisi la vérité
et vous vous avez choisi jobs hayden
comme prochain président des états unis
d'amérique
joe est un guérisseur
c'est quelqu'un qui unifie les gens
c'est une main et prouver sa propre
expérience personnelle de la perte nous
aide et nous aidera en tant que nation
nous mêmes nous pouvons puiser à même
notre mission supérieure et encore une
fois c'est cet amour son amour fondée
sur l'amour de jean bart hayden qui sera
une première dame des etats-unis
exceptionnel c'est son amour pour elle
est porteur et ashley et ses petits
enfants et toute la famille byden qui le
guide
[Applaudissements]
hariri gatineau lorsque j'ai décidé de
devenir colistière
j'ai d'abord appris à connaître jo comme
l'amoureux de sa femme j ai donc je
dirai à mon mari dogs aux enfants et à
ma soeur maya toute ma famille
j'aimerais vous dire que je vous aime
plus que je ne pourrai jamais en
témoigner article nous sommes emplis de
gratitude envers joe et jill ils nous
accueillent dans leur famille dans ce
périple extraordinaire et la femme qui
le plus responsable de ma venue ici
c'est chamallah groupes à risque et ma
mère merci à elle elle est toujours et
demeura toujours dans mon coeur
lorsqu'elle est venue ici depuis l'inde
à l'âge de 19 ans aux états unis au
début ne pouvait s'imaginer que ce jour
arriverait mais elle croyait tellement
aux états unis comme moments comme celui
ci puisse arriver à jour et donc je
pense à ma mère aujourd'hui et je pense
aux générations de femmes des femmes
noires
et
pour femmes asiatiques aux femmes
blanches aux femmes latino américaine
aux femmes des premières nations aux
autochtones qui durant toute l'histoire
de notre nation ont pavé la voie est
rendu possible ce moment d'aujourd'hui
je pense à ces femmes qui se sont
battues qui se sont sacrifiés tellement
pour l'égalité et pour la liberté ainsi
que pour la justice pour tous incluant
les femmes noires qui souvent bien trop
souvent sont négligés mais qui souvent
ont démontré qu'elles sont l'ossature
même de notre démocratie
la moelle épinière de notre démocratie
toutes ces femmes qui ont travaillé afin
de garantir et protéger le droit de vote
depuis plus de 100 ans
il y avait le 19 une 19e amendement il
ya cent ans 59 ans avec le droit boeing
est maintenant une nouvelle génération
de femmes se battent dans notre pays
elles ont décidé de voter ces femmes et
de mener plus avant leurs luttes pour
défendre les droits fondamentaux afin
d'être écouté
ce soir je réfléchis à leur lutte à leur
détermination et je pense à la force de
leur vision
elles ont pu voir entre voir ce qui est
possible ce qui peut être allégée au
delà des obstacles du passé je repose
sur leurs épaules et a eu l'audace de
briser une nuit des barrières les plus
significatives qui existait au pays
or me permettant d'être co listière et
donc de fracasser le plafond de verre
qui existe depuis longtemps mais alors
que je peux être peut-être donc la
première vice-présidente américaine la
première femme à occuper ce poste
je ne serai donc pas la dernière car
chaque petite fille qui regardent
aujourd'hui voit ce pays est un pays de
possibilités et aux enfants de notre
pays
peu importe votre genre je vous dirais
que notre pays vous a envoyé un message
clair osé rêver avec ambition soyez des
lieder de conviction et voyez vous même
comme peut-être les autres ne nous
voient pas ne vous voit pas tout
simplement parce qu'ils n'ont pas vu
votre potentiel encore mais nous allons
vous applaudir sachez le à chaque étape
de votre développement
gd met à crier au peuple américain je
dirais peu importe pour qui vous avez
voté je vais m'efforcer d'être une
novice pris ce premier bain présidente
et c'est la même chose que jo je vais
être honnête loyal je vais être préparé
en tant que vice présidente je vais
penser à vous tous les jours je serai
prête pour défendre notre pays et vous
défendre car le véritable travail
commence maintenant le travail
d'acharnement nécessaire le bon travail
être effectué le travail essentiel qu'il
nous reste à faire afin de sauver la vie
des américains est de battre l'épidémie
afin de reconstruire notre économie afin
qu'elle puisse aider les travailleurs
afin d'éliminer de déraciner une fois
pour toutes le racisme systémique pour
lutter contre la crise de notre pays
pour unir notre pays et guérir l'âme
même de notre nation
[Applaudissements]
la route à suivre vers l'avenir ne sera
pas facile entre t mais les états unis
d'amérique sont prêts et joe ainsi que
moi-même nous aussi nous sommes prêts
là nous avons élu un président qui
représente le meilleur de nous mêmes un
leader que le monde respectera et que
nos enfants respecteront tel modèle
exemplaire
un leader qui va respecter l'armée notre
armée et qui va maintenir en sécurité
notre pays ce sera un président pour
tous les américains
[Applaudissements]